foreign
[Music]
guilts is a Scourge in this country and
a problem we often talk about on the
show a video that recently went viral
from Tick Tock seems to have captured
this phenomenon perhaps better than
anything else we've seen uh here it is
you know what while we're on the topic
of how white people are just [ __ ] the
world up for everyone
you're not one of the good white people
there are no good white people there are
only anti-racist white people and racist
white people anti-racism is a lifelong
project and the end goal is not for you
to be good it's for society to be good
decenter yourself
do the work it's hard you're going to
get it wrong but if you are not out
there every day actively trying to
understand
you're not a good white person stop
patting yourself on the back stop
congratulating each other stop
separating us from the bad white people
don't sit out there in comments and say
we don't claim them we are them we are
them
we are the ones shooting up schools we
are the ones raping people
we are the ones enslaving people we are
we're them
well speak for yourself lady I have in
fact never done any of those things and
uh of the people who have done them they
are not exclusively white not even close
in fact when it comes to mass shootings
and violent crime in particular white
people are underrepresented as a group
in that category as for slavery
forms of the practice do still exist in
the world but they are happening in
parts of the world with names like India
and Africa and Southeast Asia
um these are not predominantly white
areas of the globe just to be clear but
I'm not really interested in fact
checking this poor unfortunate um I'm
assuming quite lonely white guilt
plagued woman this this actually is
someone that I feel sorry for
um
needless to say you know she has no
notion of what actually happens in the
world much less what has happened in the
world her grasp on History being even
more precarious than her understanding
of current events this is a person like
so many others in our culture who exists
in a bubble and the atmosphere inside
that bubble is comprised almost entirely
of self-loathing and narcissism
it is a volatile often quite confusing
mix and that's why I really like to use
this lady as a as a case study and
conduct something of a psychological
evaluation of the white guilt Brigade
every member of the Brigade as an
individual brought to this sorry State
through their own relatively unique set
of circumstances yet there are some
obvious through lines here some things
they all seem to have in common
and we can see many of those things
manifested in this video so let's go
through this uh Point by point three
points particular first
white Guild can either be performative
or sincere and sometimes perhaps usually
a mix of the two the fully performative
variety is usually found among the white
people who have gotten into the race
hustling business and who are profiting
immensely off of it they're the ones who
are writing the books they're the ones
who are giving Dei seminars and so on
and for them this is a scam you know
it's a it's a kind of a
Ponzi scheme it's a business opportunity
they're like the televangelists and the
private jets they found a way to profit
off of a belief system that they
probably don't subscribe to themselves
but the disciples really do believe it
to some extent at least partier on the
economy means that essential practical
gifts will be in high demand this year
give the most essential gift of all
America's best meat and seafood from
good ranchers the discounts on orders of
five boxes or more you can save on gifts
for the whole family when you give a box
of good ranchers you're giving them a
true Steakhouse experience with 100
American USDA prime and uppercut Choice
choices of beef Chicken and Seafood
other meat delivery companies and even
your local grocery stores import lower
Quality Meat from overseas don't give
your friends and family less than
America's best this year not sure what
to order well good ranchers now offers
gift cards so you can let your friends
and family choose for themselves what
they want or you can give the gift of a
subscription and inflation-proof
someone's meat budget for them go to
goodranchors.com use code Walsh at
checkout to get 35 off your gift that is
goodranchers.com code Walsh for 35 off
good ranchers American Meat delivered
this woman I'm going to assume is not
making millions selling anti-racist
books or posting anti-racism seminars
she's the person buying the books and
attending the seminars
she's spending money on the racket not
making it
that's because as you can tell just from
that one minute clip she really does buy
into this nonsense she actually does
hate herself
and that's the point the anti-racism
snake oil salesman
are exploiting the self-loathing of
people like this
she was already lonely she already had a
low self-image she already hated herself
before she ever discovered anti-racism
or learned the vapid meaningless mantras
like do the work
anti-racism simply gave her a way of
understanding her own self-loathing it
gave her something to channel it into
and through
so what she gets out of the deal is if
not Financial profit at least um and if
not emotional stability or happiness at
least she gets a feeling of unearned
moral superiority
she hates herself that much is clear but
she also gets to feel Superior to other
white people who have not done the work
as much as she has
this is exactly the attitude that she's
ranting against in the video but she is
lecturing other white people for their
feelings of superiority while herself
standing on a perch of moral superiority
this is ultimately the promise of
anti-racism
this is the reward that it offers to
White disciples
it will not make you feel better about
yourself it will not give you happiness
but it will at least make you feel
holier than those other white scumbags
second
it's interesting to note
how white women in particular seem to be
so susceptible to this stuff
most of these sorts of videos and I've
seen too many of them are made by women
and if you if you talk to anyone who's
ever been to an anti-racism seminar
um they will tell you that it's usually
a majority women
and I think that's because most
obviously women tend to be more
emotional which is which is a good thing
generally you know a man might sometimes
complain about the overly emotional
women in his life but the truth is that
he wouldn't want it any other way his
wife or girlfriend's emotional Outburst
might annoy him sometimes but he
certainly would rather she be emotional
than cold and distant this is the nature
of the two Sexes right the things that
frustrate us about each other the most
are the things that we love about each
other the most but a woman's more
emotional nature can make her easier to
emotionally manipulate in this way and
in particular women are more naturally
empathetic than men
now this again is a positive trait it's
something that men love about women
yet that empathy if not properly
calibrated and pointed in the right
direction can be exploited and
weaponized and turned against itself
white guilt is in in part a sort of
misplaced mangled perverse deranged form
of empathy
it's not entirely unlike you know the
psychology that leads some women to
strike up love affairs with murderers in
prison
kind of a similar thing going on third
final point
whether it's a man or a woman expressing
their anti-racist white guilt what we're
also seeing is the religious impulse at
work
this is maybe the most important point
to understand there is there is uh no
escaping the fact that man that man is
religious by Nature we naturally search
for the Transcendent truths that will
give our lives meaning
not only that but we naturally recognize
our own sin our own guilt
and we look for ways of relieving
ourselves of that burden we seek
atonement we seek absolution
we seek penance
anti-racism provides an outlet for those
desires it's the wrong Outlet
it's wholly unsatisfying and
insufficient but it's the sort of
religion that non-religious secular
Liberals are stuck with this is all they
got
the religion has borrowed you know the
concept of it borrows a lot of the
concepts because it doesn't create
anything of its own
leftism never does so it can only borrow
from what already exists
in this case it borrows the concept of
original sin
from Christianity
and comes up with its own warped version
of course in Christian theology original
sin is guilt shared by all people
everywhere we are flawed we are a fallen
race you know and by race we mean the
human race
but the leftist anti-racist religion
preaches about a flawed and Fallen race
meaning specifically the white race
we white people are the carriers of
original sin
while the other races are Angelic
Guiltless uncorrupted beings
this is their mythology it's their
creation story
it's their religion
because we all need religion
and we will end up with one one way or
another
and so in some ways this person being
liberal lonely sad self-loathing and
also a woman she was destined to fall
into the anti-racism religion The
anti-racism Cult
was always going to end up this way
these days
and yet she is still today I must say in
spite of that canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as you move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]